Now watch here. I'm going to show you
something.
Watch here. This dude is on fire. He's a
Baptist. When a Muslim came to pray
outside his Baptist church, look how he
treated him. Masculine Christianity,
baby.
Biblical Christianity, not the
offendment of the Jes.
Love you, D. But I'm trying to only let
the old Sam surface when necessary.
Where Jesus? By the way, I had a date
last night. It was perfect. Tomorrow,
I'll try a grape. [laughter]
Right here. This dude right here.
What are you doing, me?
>> Oh, you can't pray here. Don't come here
and pray.
>> Do not come here and prayers here. This
is a Christian Baptist church.
>> What is next?
>> You heard me.
>> What did you say? There's a dumpster
where you can pray those things AT
[screaming]
>> Did you hear what he said?
>> You're a Muslim. You want to pray
outside? This is a Christian Baptist
church. You want to pray, go to the
dumpster. That's where your prayers
belong.
>> Christianity there. You know,
[music]
>> sensational. If
>> See,
I love this dude. Where are you guys?
Where you smileless dudes at? Watch it
again.
What are you doing? Pray.
>> Oh, you can't pray here. Don't come here
and pray. Do not come here and pray in
honor of prayers here. This is a
Christian Baptist church.
>> You heard me.
>> There's a dumpster where you can pray
those things AT
[screaming]
>> this
[music]
sensation. This dude right here put a
lot of Catholics and Orthodox to shame.
Not all.
Now, you and I believe there are true
believers born of the spirit in all
these churches. God meets you where
you're at. If you don't know any better,
Amen. But you know, a Baptist church is
a building, right?
Because it's not structured
in line with the biblical design of how
the temple of God should be. Now we are
the living temple. The Holy Spirit lives
in us. But we have to come together and
have an altar where the sacrifice of
Lord Jesus Christ is given to us for our
healing, strength, and nourishment. They
don't have that. You see how zealous
they are for [snorts] their church?
How much more should you be zealous for
the Orthodox church, the Catholic
church, right? Be it oriental Orthodox,
Eastern Orthodox, Assyrian church,
right? When you believe you have a holy
altar and on the altar you have the holy
sacrifice, the actual physical body and
blood of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ,
how much more zealous would you be to
keep away paganism, Satanism, which is
what Islam is, [snorts] far away from
your place of worship,
right?
If you're a Christian and that video
bothers you, you're part of the problem.
You're the reason why false religions
can come into this country, disrespect,
>> you're what?
>> Sensational. If you're a Christian and
that video bothers you, you're part of
the problem. You're the reason why false
religions can come into this country,
disrespect Jesus Christ in his church.
Because what are Christians going to do
about it? They're a bunch of spineless,
disloyal, compromising people anyway who
refuse to defend the God that they claim
to believe in. Preaching tolerance of
false religion more than preaching Jesus
Christ being the only way, the truth,
and the life.
>> Damn. A Baptist preacher has to tell us
that. Damn, Gina.
Damn.
And that no man cometh unto the father
but by him. And for those of you asking,
pastor, would Jesus have done what you
did? The answer is no. He wouldn't. He
would have been a lot harsher. No.
Would Jesus have done what you did? No,
he he wouldn't. He would have been a lot
harsher than me.
Damn, Gina
did. The answer is no. He wouldn't. He
would have been a lot harsher. He would
have made a scourge of small cords and
drove him out all the while flipping
tables. Not to mention what he did to
false prophets in the Old Testament.
In your face, you guys. Sam, I don't see
Jathan. You're that old Sam with too
nasty. You know, you know, I wish, you
know, Sam would just swear just a little
less and stop using biblical
descriptions to describe false teachers.
You know, when he calls people
even he means the great of
Babylon, the mother of all and
calls them dogs and pigs and and says,
you know, smear on your faith and
maybe your God is out to the toilet, you
know, side in Malachi 2:3 or First Kings
18:27 and the example of Elijah. I was
saying, "Stop talking like that."
I wish he stopped talking like that. Or
when Jesus says you are
adulterers basically you're all
in Matthew 16 verse4 you know Matthew 12
verse 39 you know I wish Sam stop
talking like that or where where Jesus
said you fools you know in Matthew 23:17
and that word is the same word for
and stupid and I wish Sam stop talking
like this I want to see Jesus and them I
WANT TO SEE JESUS AND them
>> and what he's going to do to them in the
new read up. It's absurd to think that
Christians are willing to be tolerant
towards false religion as if God's not
bothered by it. Whatever happens, have
no fellowship with the unfruitful works
of darkness, but rather reprove them.
Whatever happened to if any come unto
you and have not this doctrine, receive
them not into your house, neither bid
him God speed, for is King James only.
What happened, man? A Baptist on fire,
dude. Believes every word of that Bible,
unlike Michael Loftton. And he's willing
to die for it and fight for it. He that
bidth him God speed is a partaker of his
evil deeds. Whatever happened to you,
though we or an angel preach any other
gospel unto you than that which we have
preached unto you, let him be a curse.
Whatever happened to you, be not
unequally yolked together with
unbelievers? For what fellowship hath
righteousness with unrighteousness? What
communion hath light with darkness? What
concord hath Christ with bio? What part
hath he that believeth with an infidel?
Notice quoting it from memory. And he's
a King James only Baptist. memory 2
Corinthians 6:14
to 18 but specifically 2 Corinthians
6:14- 15 2 John it's only one chapter
verse 71 specifically 10-11
from memory yeah Ephesians 5:11
what agreement had the temple of God
with idols [music] it's high time the
pastor stop walking on eggshells and
start standing for the name of Jesus
Christ unapologetically regardless of
the ramifications
>> you got it ain't that a sad thing sad
That song they say. Now the verse he
quoted and we're going to get into I
promise you. So I'll warm up. Second
John is only one chapter. What does John
say about people who come preaching a
different gospel? Missionaries who are
presenting another Jesus.
Another Jesus. What the heck happened
here, dude? Oops. You're not supposed to
see that there. All right. Another
Jesus.
A different spirit. when they come
looking for lodging for food and
financial support. I'm going to tell you
what it does to me because people
misunderstand this. Let's read from 7 to
11. Let me see if the screen is large
enough.
All right. Lord Jesus Christ, where you
been, bro? Shoot. You you two are too
late, Holmes. Here
he was quoting 10 to 11. However, we're
going to read 7 to11. For many deceivers
have gone out into the world, those who
do not confess Jesus Christ is coming in
the flesh. These are the protonostics.
Nostism was on the rise and they believe
that the divine Christ would never
become flesh because to them matter was
evil. So John is warning the Christians,
these heretics who are now bastardizing
Christianity with their Greek philosophy
that matter is evil. Christ is a divine
being who would never become flesh
because then he would pollute and taint
himself. but only appeared as if he was
a man with a physical body. If they deny
that he came in the flesh, they are
deceivers. Protonnostic group already
being condemned. And yet Michelle Ltonia
is telling us there were Christian
groups that would quote from the gospel
of Thomas agnostic gospel with the
canonical gospel because they were very
fluid. You know these Christian groups.
So now he's calling the Gnostic
Christian.
Okay.
got that son of his right hand.
Paul and John were already condemning
the rise ofnosticism
nosis. These Greeks were bastardized
Christianity with their view inherited
from Greek philosophy that matter is
evil, bodies are evil, the soul is pure
and you want to live forever as a
disembodied soul. antithetical to the
Old Testament and teachings of the
historical Jesus who confirmed the Old
Testament. So they believed Christ was
divine.
But if he's divine and the body is evil,
he wouldn't become flesh. So either
appeared as if he was a man, a phantom
body, or the divine Christ possessed and
indwelt the man Jesus. And when the man
Jesus was crucified, the divine Christ
left him and looked at a distance. John
is already condemning them
and that's what Ignatian says about
them. The dositist from the verb do do
appears he says they do not partake of
the Eucharist since they deny it's the
flesh of our Lord Jesus Christ. So
Ignatius and I witness to the apostles
disciple of the apostle John is already
mentioning them. They don't partake of
the Eucharist because they deny it's the
flesh of our Lord Jesus Christ because
they don't believe Christ became flesh.
Okay, we got it.
Yep.
This is the deceiver and the Antichrist.
See to yourselves [clears throat]
that you do not lose what we accomplish
in it. See, bye-bye once saved always
saved.
You started the race, but you can lose
all that you've done. All that work can
be in vain. If you entertain these
people, if you fellowship with these
people and give these people legitimacy
[clears throat] and a platform, then you
will be cut off with them and lose your
reward. See that?
Bye-bye. Once saved, always saved.
Anyone who goes too far and does not
abide in teaching Christ does not have
God. You must abide. There's that
abiding. What is faith? Being faithful.
How do you be faithful? By abiding in
Christ. Abiding in the Holy Spirit to
energize you. Do what Christ says. And
if you sin, confess and repent. No
matter how many times you sin, keep
confessing.
Don't justify sin. Don't stop confessing
until you die.
See,
the one abides in the teaching, he has
both the father and the son. If anyone
comes to you and does not bring this
teaching, do not receive him into your
house. Do not give him a greeting. Do
you see that? you effeminate Christians.
Now, let me explain what this does not
mean. You guys are not bored, right? As
I prepare you for the main course. This
is all appetizer.
John is not saying don't let a Jehovah
witness or a Mormon in your house to
witness to them.
What he means here is it preachers would
travel and would depend on the
hospitality people to give them a home,
lodging, food, and financial support.
So if I'm an itinerant preacher, but I'm
preaching nasticism
or I'm preaching adoptionism,
you are not to allow me to stay in your
house for whatever period of time I
remain in that place, feed me and give
me money to spread my heresy because
I'll be condemned with him.
You understand what this means now? What
this means is you share
in either the work of the man,
which means you either share in their
blessing or judgment.
Now, let me tie it in. I'm not
manipulating you here. The person you
support doing the work of God, you share
in the fruit of that man's labor. So if
God has used this ministry to lead
millions, you who have been praying for
me and supporting me financially, that
will also be credited to you. You'll be
rewarded for it. But if you're
supporting a false teacher who's
preaching a false gospel and you're
supporting him financially
and due to your support, you're enabling
him to mislead people, you will share in
the wrath and judgment of that false
teacher.
See that?
Do you get it? Now the warning here
what John is saying, you will lose your
reward and all that good work will be in
vain.
If you lodge a false teacher, feed a
false teacher, enable a false teacher to
preach his lies and support him, you
will be destroyed with him.
See why I say Michael Loftton is a tool
of Satan.
He fed off of Catholics all this time
when he was a wolf in sheep's clothing.
For the one who gives him a greeting
participates in his evil deeds right
there. See,
you share.
So why would I want to legitimize false
teachers by
supporting them financially and giving
them a place to stay so they can roam in
the city to deceive people with their
false gospel.
This what the Baptist preacher was
saying.
Okay, so we got that out of the way.